how to describe this great for those of
you who don't know Tywin does not play
when it comes to food so I thought it
would be fun to invite some of my
friends who've never had it before and
see what they think of it I don't think
I've ever had Taiwanese food I've had
Chinese food probably had it once
without knowing it
hey song sarsaparilla
Oh woah what this is root beer I'm gonna
put ice cream in it like bubblegum
bubblegum some apple juice
bubblegum yeah little bit like a cream
soda yeah well like it's very very sweet
this looks like Korean pancakes it's
very buttery there's oil in between
every layer of this I would dip it in
sauce yeah there's like flaky layers
watching your peel pave I'm diggin it it
reminds me a lot of like latkes every
culture has something like a toy yeah
that definitely tastes Asian so is that
garlic is it just straight-up cloves of
garlic it doesn't have like the spice
taste a lot of sausages have come on no
like it no no it's nothing I'm like it I
didn't haven't tasted this before it's
kind of sweet but it's like a good sweet
I don't get it because sausage is ground
up but this doesn't look ground up it
looks like it was hand
I love the garlic with it I'm not mad at
that I love garlic but it's a decision
to eat straight garlic oh my god no so
good this is a book tour it's great I
really like this refreshing in nature
eat this is definitely like a lighter
dish you would have it's not too salty
and it's not too sweet good so who knows
ooh the thing is but is that the bait
gets overcooked yeah I gotta take you to
better places done
oh my gosh it is like bulgogi yeah I was
about to say this looks kind of like
bulgogi Taiwanese food is really similar
to Korean food oh gosh I love dishes
that have multiple animals in them it
almost melts in your mouth so it's just
so soft as a kid I always ate rice and I
always hated eating rice because then
I'd always have to like mix it with the
meat and stuff like this but this is
like drenched in like its own sauce yeah
there were like a million ingredients in
each thing there are like three to five
ingredients in every dish but they work
very well together just like a few
ingredients all happily chilling
together in your mouth a-plus-plus get
you some Taiwanese food or get you
someone who knows how to make authentic
Taiwanese food you have bland pork crazy
is it just gonna be an ad for pork yeah
pork Roger Bob pork